all right Alex well we just got back
from seeing destiny the taken King we've
got to check out their PvP mode mayhem
basically it's like near unlimited super
mode every like 30 or 40 seconds you're
super just comes up so that means we got
a chance to see all of the supers yeah
in Destiny's the taking came there three
new sub classes which means they're
three new supers and from what I saw
them it actually seems like the supers
are gonna be pretty cool so the one that
you and I both really liked was the
Titans hammer now the Titan basically
pops a solar hammer there's a big dong
like everybody on the field knows that
it happened and then you just basically
have this rocket launcher you're just
running around the map with this hammer
just throwing it until your meter runs
out it just creates a large solar
explosion disintegrates anything in its
path it was probably the more satisfying
of the new supers yeah I'd say so too
when I got to play it I you know I
actually it ended up being sort of like
forcing me into some sort of strategy
where like I would run into a group of
enemies and pop it and just throw the
hammer as fast as possible to get as
many kills another thing that is
interesting about that though is it does
have a pretty heavy arc on it and so you
do have to actually aim your your throws
with a hammer to make sure that you hit
hit the enemy so then now the Warlock
basically has a Chain Lightning it's
like emperor palpatine's like chain
lightning from Star Wars now we found
that was a little bit underwhelming in
PvP just because you're so vulnerable
when you're using it right basically
hover in the air and you're just going
around the map shooting lightning at
your fingertips but you gotta it's like
the more like the lmg class than the
launchers you have to like really hold
it on people for a length of time yeah
exactly and it requires a little bit of
patience to use it like it can't takes a
couple seconds for it to actually you
know get a person's health down to the
point where they might die the the thing
that I liked about it though is that you
could run into a room and if they're you
know and mayhem everything is exploding
all the time so you know it's hard to
hard to see sometimes the thing about
the Warlock super which is called the
storm storm trans that's what it's
called is that you can actually
basically blind fire it you can run into
a room even if you can't see anything
and just pop it and just start firing it
and it will hit people if they were in
the room with you and then the hunter
which neither of us actually got our
hands on but we got hit by has basically
a char
arrow now now if the arrow hits you then
it automatically kills you but if it
doesn't hit you it basically creates a
sticky trap so basically the hunter I
guess finally has it their root spell
they'd never had yeah and one of the
interesting parts about this it doesn't
show up in the trailers is that as soon
as you pop it the hunter pulls back and
shoot so you don't really have any time
to aim this makes it super difficult to
actually hit an enemy and if you do you
your score an insta-kill but if you
don't it does it hits the ground
increase like you know kind of the
gravity well that pulls enemies and
blinds them now of the two maps that we
saw one was sector 6 18 which took place
inside the fortified wall of the old
city that one was basically just kind of
a jumping platforming map yeah but the
more interesting one was the cross road
map which basically had the mana pole it
was only a matter of time before man
catapults came back budgie we knew that
you were gonna do that yep bungee you
know they're known for their halo maps
and those halo maps all oftentimes have
teleporters and Mankins all sorts of
stuff that can flinging her around the
map and they're back in crossroads and
it's pretty great now that map was
really interesting because you basically
have the catapults going over the middle
so you know players would be crossing
each other in the middle you're
definitely get this the typical sniping
of people in midair but then at the back
of the map on either side there's a
teleporter so you can actually run to
the back of the map and flip all the way
to the other side so that means you're
gonna get this great like mayhem as the
mode intense where people are basically
dropping supers flying through the
middle and then crossing through the
back of the map constantly yeah and
another thing that I personally liked
about this map is it has really long
sight lines which means that they're
going to be some awesome sniper gameplay
which destiny is kind of lacking at the
moment so I really like them up and you
and I both flip through the gear just a
little bit to see what the taken King
had we saw some pretty cool like saw
some prequel future war cult ships in
the beginning but also the weapons were
a little bit different there was a
suppressed pistol in my secondary or
suppressed sidearm I guess it's called
so I don't know suppressors I haven't
really seen that yet yeah and also the
the gear now has a little bit of boost
for like things like agility and
strength and stuff so like I saw one of
my boots that was if you get a kill with
the melee it'll boost your agility 45
seconds after that so that's pretty cool
as well so overall I think taking King
at least from a PvP perspective seems to
be shaping up well the vidoc that
you know everybody got to see shows at
the rate and everything is coming along
so I guess next up we'll have to see and
try to get her hands on what these
supers do in the PVD environment yeah
definitely well for more coverage of
Destiny taken King stay tuned to
gamespot com